in a rome hospital we step
into a world that only deals with covid
nursing staff wearing the hot and
uncomfortable protective uniforms
designed to keep them safe
in every room on this floor there are
patients seriously ill with the virus
and more keep on coming
it's exhausting work both physically and
mentally for the team
we are trying to to stay
next to the patient as they are alone
long they they don't see the family they
don't speak with the
with the family with their parents with
the wife husband
they are all alone here they say they
will be able to make more beds available
at least for the next few weeks
but with cases rising medical staff
across the capital
are already struggling to cope
at torvagatta hospital the head of
nursing and intensive care
readies herself to enter a unit where
all the beds currently
allocated to covered patients are full
where the second wave
they know how hard it's going to get
the premium
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
close by and from the safety of a
corridor in the infectious
diseases department we are shown the
rooms which are now
all occupied by covid patients just days
ago at this hospital
ambulances cued for up to nine hours to
admit patients
and senior staff say there is only one
solution to this covert crisis
a national lockdown i think that
the only possibility is a lockdown so
i think that it's very important to
start quickly in lockdown
and to stop the the
pandemia so this is the only
possibility because there is no
possibility to to have
sufficient beds in the hospital for
these patients
a stark statement from those who fear
impossible pressures on the health
service
but for now lockdown is a move the
italian government resists
what happens in the nation's hospitals
in the coming days
may force a change in political strategy
michelle clifford sky news rome